boa tarde a todos
meu nome é getúlio vargas o engenheiro
de produção formado aqui na casa há
muito tempo atrás
vamos falar idade é bom nosso projeto
começou o mês sem querer se era eu ea
ana esposa como cidadão focado em
resolver o problema de causa animal do
uso de animais de grande porte em tração
carroça que a gente vê muito nas cidades
assim carroças abarrotadas de ddd
no geral e em tudo que papel de 9
a gente sempre quis na verdade alguma
coisa que substituísse aquilo tirar o
animal de cena pudesse alguma coisa num
mundo que a gente vive hoje tão moderno
tantas coisas maravilhosas acontecendo
nós usando um veículo de transporte
medieval é uma coisa meio aceitável
ainda mais porque os animais sofre é
tudo tem um limite
e pra eles também têm na maioria das
vezes não é respeitado num final de 2012
a gente começou a pensar em alguma coisa
que fosse barata que fosse simples assim
de manter um provocador até então nesse
momento a gente não não pensava que a
crescer que a ganhar outras áreas era
algo meio lúdico
era um projeto só para apresentar à
sociedade digamos assim ele o tempo iria
dizer se estava no correto ou não ea
gente e eu como engenheiro então
projetei o primeiro veículo baseado em
bicicleta que era para ser algo simples
e com alguma ajuda de um motor elétrico
para eles poderem trabalhar e coletar e
e fazer o seu percurso sem tanto esforço
não é porque mesmo a gente sabendo
o qq pedalando também ficou foi o pedal
dinheiro vai tomar um jogador que vai
chegar ao fim do dia também não vai ter
perna para tudo trabalho do dia
carregar peso preciso de uma ajuda de um
motor elétrico
ainda mais se tu pensar em uma categoria
que precisa todo dia né eles peguem
coleta o dia e no fim do dia geralmente
passam por algum tipo de atravessadores
recebe no fim do dia
então se ele não for trabalhar no dia
vão ter que comer de noite a gente
lançou aqui é uma falta dodô
a gente quando fala do projeto e faz o
projeto em cad é isso era uma foto dele
um projeto computador ea gente depois de
um tempo lançou o primeiro modelo um
pouco alterada assim algumas peças de
scooter elétrica pedais veículo que
pesava perto de 200 quilos tinha dois
motores em cada roda tinha pedal elevada
em torno de 350 quilos
andava em torno de 40 quilômetros de
autonomia foi bem legal de andar e até
pra fazer as coisas normais assim uma
pessoa normal além do trabalho de coleta
que foi visada fazer a gente então como
ia ter a resposta se este veículo
funciona não a gente procurou
cooperativa da cidade
pra que formará parceria eles descerem
para nós vocês estão no caminho não o
seu veículo funciona
por sorte a nossa cooperativa também ela
tem uma certa organização aqui na cidade
ela já presta um serviço pra prefeitura
um termo de cooperação entre eles então
poder testar uma maneira mais efetiva e
eles me disseram que eu estava no
caminho se estava certo ou não
muitas vezes a gente como o dinheiro às
vezes projetos das coisas e oferece
própria pessoa achando que é grande
coisa mas na verdade o outro lado que
que faz funcionar e que trabalha que vai
te dizer se está no caminho não e quando
a gente chegou lá o volume de material
que ele trabalha é muito grande então a
gente precisava
no caso dele aumentar o tamanho é e
porque porque eles na maioria das vezes
fazemos um caminhão e um caminhão
consome muito
e pra gente que sobrevive vendendo papel
plástico chega no fim do dia não sobra
muito se tiver que pagar combustível
ainda mais os valores que estão hoje ou
mesmo a manutenção de um caminhão né não
sobra é uma conta que não se paga e eles
vão voltar a usar a cavalo
então logo em seguida a gente também
lançou o segundo modelo e segundo modelo
de tamanho de uma caminhonete levando em
torno de uma tonelada
ele andava com engate de reboque também
aqui uma foto feito no estádio beira rio
na copa dentro da copa do mundo ea gente
usava ele diariamente na cooperativa
onde diariamente é realmente todo dia
por durante três anos
aqui é mais uma foto vocês têm noção da
capacidade de de carga dele ele
trabalhava realmente comum era uma visão
de empresa né porque não adianta
oferecer coisas na categoria que precisa
ser auxiliado e não e não provar que
funciona realmente o que acontece muitas
vezes a gente prejulga até mesmo a
própria classe dos catadores e ter a
gente b eles fazendo algo para o animal
mas não se coloca na situação dele e
também não valoriza que a coleta
seletiva ela precisa ser feita
o que a gente nosso consumismo da raça
humana
a cada meio ano a gente tem que comprar
um celular novo a natureza tem limite e
já está dando o sinai e isso a gente vê
isso todo dia que acontece a gente
precisa da reciclagem o trabalho deles é
importante apesar de não valorizar eles
porque se a gente sempre puxa eles
naquela parte de comparar o lixo lixo
não tem valor e as pessoas que estão
nesse meio tempo não tem valor
só que as empresas que coletam o nosso
lixo e levam para aterros de um muito
dinheiro então o serviço de coleta é que
é o importante hoje em dia mas a gente
não valoriza a eles que não vêem como
empresa e eles por serem pobres muitas
vezes não têm a capacidade de se
organizar e não conseguem passar a ter
uma segurança ou até mesmo óbitos
é um mais comercial o que deveria ser
feito na minha opinião essas parcerias
público e governo para que possam
auxiliar e agente precisa de reciclagem
não consegue tirar todo o papel que foi
para um aterro na verdade um aterro nada
mais é do que uma lata de lixo gigante
ele estava um de terra e aquino demora
vamos lá 500 600 anos e todo aquele
material todo aquele papel tem plástica
tem que ser tirado da natureza novamente
a natureza ela não suporta mais o nosso
estilo de vida da humanidade ea gente na
verdade empurra tudo isso com a barriga
porque ainda não estamos brigando por um
copo d'água limpa
no momento que nós tivemos que brigar aí
não vai adiantar nós falamos de
reciclagem
uma das desvantagens que a gente viu
logo no começo a inclusão social e se
sentem bem andando de carrinho
eles se sentem participando ele eles
trabalham mais trabalho mais feliz se
sentem mais aceitos assim um veículo que
ninguém tem rodando veículo elétrico
então a gente tinha muito o volume as
pessoas queriam que o veículo passasse
na sua loja e levar seu papel pra eles
porque se sentiam participantes que era
um projecto com uma visão moderna do
evento os maus tratos principal os
carros chineses são o principal fator é
demonstrado a cavalo
só que há a coleta ainda não rendi para
manter um cavalo que sobra de grana pra
eles no fim do dia acaba indo pra comida
e não só para manter o cavalo
acontece que os cavalos vão ser laurindo
e é mais fácil para eles comprar um
outro do que por manter propriamente um
cavalo errado bem alimentado
muitas vezes as doenças eles levam os
cavalos e mantém perto de casa porque
não tem shaka precisa de choque mas não
tem
então ele precisa manter o animal
próximo da onde vamos puxar a carroça eo
cavalo alado lado da casa defecando da
chove e deviam barral as crianças passam
ali no meio sabe muitas vezes leva os
cavalos defecando no centro da cidade ea
sociedade cobra de cabanhas
cavalos mais nobres assim que passa a
até 6.000 infecciosa teste de mormo né
isso os cavalos estão rodando no meio da
grande cidade e ninguém cobra nada
porque é uma faixa da população que
precisa atenção mas na verdade eles
podem estar se espalhando para todo
mundo em algum tipo de zoonose
principalmente para as crianças que vão
parar de porto no serviço público de
saúde trânsito isso é é uma das coisas
mais vitais
geralmente deixa o cavalo amarrado
próximos a terrenos do antigo de
estradas geralmente os animais se soltam
ou e se assusta no trânsito da carroça
gente acompanha muitos animais que tem o
olho do trânsito que eles chama olho
voltado portanto ele é furado para que o
alemão não deseja usar os carros
passando e não tenham risco de se
assustar e correr
essa é uma foto foi tirada até ontem na
própria cidade aqui e o animal na
verdade ele depois que se machucou que
ele quebra alguma coisa difícil de
tratar o animal que tem uma perna
quebrada algum tipo de coisa assim
geralmente ele só tá nasa ou ele morre à
míngua por ele mesmo ea gente nos nossos
direitos a gente sempre por toda a
segurança
a barra de proteção fita de segurança
farol da esquerda para a direita no
freio luz de ré é assim como exigem de
um carro
só que infelizmente também o governo ele
não nos deu muita chance porque ele nos
cobraram como não existe na verdade uma
uma lei que enquadra veículos elétricos
e na mais baixa velocidade nos pediram
que colocassem 3 abs e airbag do veículo
que anda 20 quilômetros por hora e quase
conseguiu né
é um exagero de custo que teria que
votar no veículo seria e não num todo
sólido pouco o problema da evolução a
gente que acabou padronizando os
veículos até mesmo pra que separar
categorias assim ver veículos que levam
até 100 200 quilos de livros que leva
uma tonelada e veículos que levam duas
toneladas
os primeiros as bicicletas acabam
levando até 100 quiser para isso ela é
boa
mais do que isso já necessitaria do
veículo maior vai caminhando não precisa
fazer um esforço que é o caso do segundo
veículo azul
a pessoa pode ficar me leva até uma
tonelada e nunca as duas maiores
veículos das camionetas que levam até
duas toneladas ano com engate de reboque
então paralisar por quê porque a gente
precisa também se enquadram em todas as
normas de segurança não pode está
testando veículos ou tentando de repente
até vender negociar algum tipo de coisa
que não se enquadra em todas as normas
de segurança
pra você ter uma idéia do que é
consumido por que que eu escolhi
veículos elétricos não são do que um ar
que tinha me diz que bonito é porque
realmente gastam pouco pega veículo
gastando de 1 a 5 centavos por
quilômetro rodado isso fizer uma
comparação básica que pegar uma
camioneta o veículo maior elétrico e
comparar com um caminhão e dois mil
quilômetros todo mesmo rodar alguns em
média mil mas bote 2011 no final de um
ano só em combustível reduziu quase 30
mil reais
estou a olhar a comparação entre eles é
reduzimos muito pouco mesmo que comparar
contra si uma caneta elétrica com três
motos uma moto
dos três mil e seiscentos reais com uma
caneta normal a diesel 10 mil reais num
ano rodando 2000
isso é muito importante porque mesmo
nível de emprego é o dinheiro que vai
sobrar pra eles é o dinheiro que vai
trabalhar para a empresa e ao dinheiro
que vai sobrar pra aquela empresa que
coleta o nosso lixo e que vai poder
baratear o preço do serviço prestado
então pro contribuinte a redução essas
medidas deveriam ser mais acobertado
pelo governo
no meio do caminho gente entrou numa
área que a gente não queria fazer muito
porque falta estrutura que o resgate dos
resgates já apareceram para nós pelo
nome cavalo de lata a proximidade aquela
muitas pessoas acabam ligando um dia uma
pessoa da cooperativa nos ligou chorando
de manhã dizendo que uma égua tinha
caído e machucado
a pata e que estava
vendo e na verdade nós sem sabermos como
lidar com cavalos né a gente foi até lá
e ver o que poderíamos fazer como
cidadão de novo que a gente pode fazer
chegou lá e conseguimos resgatar
conseguimos levantar ela e assim foram
surgindo também depois dela outros
nesse último ano e meio mas e foi em pé
dos 20 mais de 30 cavalos têm todos são
salvos
a gente faz todo o tratamento de içá de
saúde hoje né a gente abrir uma ong
inclusive pra isso pra tratar mais dessa
parte social e dos animais porque ter
animais demanda que tenha campo que
tenha razão que tem a alimentação que
tenham vermífugos que tenha ferraduras
isto somado uma conta o texto assim o
animal vai custar 500 reais por mês
tem que ter mais ou menos um animal
trabalho pior ainda vai ter que ter mais
e mais ação mais passe mais tempo de
descanso que a gente vê nas vidas não é
isso às vezes o cavalo chega eles passa
por um vizinho para gerar uma segunda
fonte de renda
a recuperação demora
isso aqui é uma foto de um exemplo do
cavalo de um ano que passou com nota que
chega à míngua demora um ano
em geral a maioria dos cavalos a gente
perde é porque ele passa ali os seus
últimos dez quinze dias conosco e acaba
morrendo porque já chegam muito
debilitados hoje em dia mais barato usar
um cavalo até à míngua do que
propriamente mantém ele com cinco sacos
por mês de ração e mais vermelhos mais
dura cavalo morna apesar de ser robusta
no qual ele é um animal que morre por
qualquer coisa ele morre por cole que
ele morre por todos não é pro fé de modo
um dia para o outro não é um apesar de
ser forte não um animal tão simples de
se manter a gente chegou nas filas
muitas vezes não é que o local onde
gente viu que precisa não é só o catador
que também precisa de uma ajuda mas
também as pessoas saberem dos carros fez
muitas vezes chega lá e não têm nada
para comer e chegou às famílias que a
criança chegava e perguntava o que nós
queremos dar pra ele ele pedia leite da
ilha chegaram na geladeira do cara ele e
ele só tinha água dentro da geladeira e
no entanto vê se não trabalhar todas e
não vai resolver situações incomuns
veículos elétricos ajudando catadores
que é necessário tanto precisa pensar
nas famílias não adianta tirar o cavalo
dele que ele vai morrer ele não vai ter
onde ele vai pegar outro cavalo
ele precisa então muitas vezes a gente
não adianta só ficar com raiva porque
ele podia do cavalo que a sociedade o
dia dele fazendo com o cavalo faz isso
com os filhos é uma vida mais dura do
que a gente na nossa classe social a
gente às vezes não sabe por que não
passa por isso
então a gente criou o processo de
transição que é o processo de transição
a gente chega na família que tem um
cavalo a gente conversa com eles do que
vocês sessão carroceiros vocês estão
carroceiros e aí ele vem para nós o que
eles querem da vida mais ou menos ea
gente negocia com ele só eu tiro eu
quero ter um cavalo
em troca disso consigo de repente um
emprego para tinha consigo alimentação
por 23 meses e nesse tempo enquanto se
cria um novo ambiente para o seu
sustento para o cavalo
a gente te ajuda e passa o cavalo ea
carroça pornô
dessa maneira a gente pega uma maneira
mais ampla tem muitas empresas na cidade
tem muito trabalho muitas vezes não
aceita porque não têm escolaridade então
a gente através da nossa rede e aí eu
falo não é só eu que um monte de gente
inclusive aqui no palco na palestra aqui
que nos ajuda que nos faça possível uma
pessoa só não faz tudo isso o
desenvolvimento da sociedade e aceitação
porque sozinho não adianta eu vou votar
naquela pessoa ele vai resolver todos os
problemas pra mim não há gente como a
sociedade precisa mudar
o dida precisa aceitar que as coisas
precisam mudar e realmente cuidar ficar
só esperando não vai chegar um momento
que não temos uma saída eu agradeço
muito a todos puderam que a brecha para
apresentar o projeto e eu gostaria
também de
e pedir clareza pra vocês que que se
engajem seja na nossa causa outras
causas
façam realmente um mundo melhor não
fique esperando a gente precisa de
mudança o tempo na verdade da mudança já
passou ea gente precisa ser mais efetivo
auxiliar pessoas a se dar boas causas
não só curtir no facebook ou coisas
assim ele precisa ser mais efetivo na
mudança e entender que o mundo está meio
de golã
muito obrigado gabriel
[Aplausos]